[Music]
foreign
can't talk in a hurry and don't let my
dad catch you out here again what come
on he doesn't like my limbs anyway June
Bloom is coming and you just got to be
my date cause check it out I'm all grown
up and I smell good
about my queen
sorry buddy elements don't mix
flame gotta go come on go to the
festival with me you'll never leave this
part of town that's because everything I
need is right here
[Music]
[Applause]
plus the city isn't made with fire
people in mind sorry but it had taken
Act of God to get me across that bridge
an act of God or an act of cool
[Music]
foreign
winner winner charcoal dead
head to bed I'll close things up still
have much to prepare for red dots sale
Dad I'll take care of it you need to
rest
how we'll learn from the best
my time there was only one thing you
haven't done tomorrow I sleep in and I
want you to run shop for Red Dot fail
seriously
without losing your temper it will show
me you are able to take over
you got it ashva
I won't let you down I swear you'll see
[Music]
good daughter
yes okay
Flame
take a breath
calm as a candle
morning welcome to the fireplace
oh whoa they're all the same just take
one from the top thanks for shopping so
many stickers for sale
wait
you have to pay before you eat
uh what's your return pops
take breath
make connections
we'll be back in five minutes
[Music]
foreign
what is wrong with me
what
a happy family is that you and your dad
I love dads
and it's your birthday
oh are you what are you doing here I
don't know I was searching for a link on
the other side of the river and got
sucked in this is bad I can't lose
another job
I just can't seem to find my flow
oh that pipe squished me all out of
shape
that's better dude just get out of here
I gotta clean this master for my dad's
he's what I did
actually
foreign
I'm afraid I'm gonna have to write you a
ticket a ticket yeah I'm a city
inspector and this pipe is definitely
not up to code I sucked a city inspector
into our pipes I know ironic right stop
messing with that well I need to make
sure it's solid everything's solid I
should know my dad rebuilt this place
himself
wait
you're dad dude yes with his bare hands
every brick and board it was a ruin when
he found it
what's up
[Music]
turn into a piper not the right
citations I could get this place shut
down oh gosh it's just too much shut us
down I know it's awful nope you can't
shut us down please this is a big day
for me it's our Red Dot sale hey take it
easy this is as hard with me as it is on
you get back here sorry I gotta get
these to City Hall before the end of my
shift
[Music]
element City
thank you
sorry sorry
[Music]